>>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
TWO YEARS AGO THIS MONTH BEFORE
THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
IN 2020 WE INTERVIEWED A FORMER
BUSINESS PARTNER OF THE BIDEN
FAMILY.
HIS NAME WAS TONY BOBULINSKI.
HE TOLD US A REMARKABLE STORY.
JOE BIDEN'S SON AND BROTHER HAD
ENTERED INTO HIGHLY LUCRATIVE
DEALS WITH FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING A COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT
OF CHINA IN WHICH THEY SOLD
ACCESS TO THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THEMSELVES.
NOW ON MANY LEVELS, THAT WAS A
CRIME.
JOE BIDEN WAS AWARE OF IT WHEN
IT HAPPENED AND JOE BIDEN
PROFITED FROM IT DIRECTLY.
IT WAS A STRONG CHARGE TO MAKE
BUT TONY BOB BELINSKY HAD THE
DOCUMENTS, E-MAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES TO PROVED IT HAPPEN.
WE CONSIDERED IT A HUGE STORY
AND WE SPENT AN HOUR ON IT IN
OCTOBER 2020.
TWO YEARS LATER WE STILL
CONSIDER IT A HUGE STORY.
IN ALL OF THAT TIME NO OTHER
MAJOR NEWS ORGANIZATION IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS BOTHERED TO FOLLOW
UP.
THE NEW YORK TIMES NEVER
INTERVIEWED TONY AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE BIDEN
FAMILY BUSINESS DEALS, WHICH IS
STRANGE BECAUSE HE WAS A PARTNER
WITH THE BIDEN FAMILY.
BUT NEITHER HAS THE WASHINGTON
POST.
NEITHER HAVE THE OTHER
TELEVISION NETWORKS.
THEY HAVE IGNORED IT.
THE FBI, WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL LAW, DID TAKE A
LENGTHY STATEMENT FROM TONY
BOBULINSKI BACK IN 2020 AND
DURING THAT CONVERSATION HE
OUTLINED SEVERAL FELONIES THE
BIDEN GIRL S HAD COMMITTED.
HE SAW IT.
HE PROVIDED EXTENSIVE
DOCUMENTATION TO PROVE THAT IT
HAPPENED.
THE AGENCY SPOKE TO SEEMED
SHOCKED AND THEY PROMISED TO GET
BACK TO TONY FOR A FOLLOW-UP
INTERVIEW.
BUT THEY NEVER DID.
THE FBI NEVER CALLED TONY
BOBULINSKI AGAIN.
NO ONE WAS EVER INDICTED FOR
THESE CRIMES.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THEM WAS
SQUELCHED.
TO THIS DATE THE FBI CONTINUES
TO SUPPRESS EVIDENCE, PROOF THAT
THE MOST POWERFUL FAMILY IN THE
COUNTRY HAS COMMITTED CRIMES
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
CORRUPTION.
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IF THE UNITED STATES IS GOING TO
CONTINUE AS A DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC WE CANNOT HAVE THIS.
IT CANNOT GO ON.
NEXT MONTH VOTERS WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO CHANGE COURSE.
THEY HAVE THE CHANCE TO
REPUDIATE THE FORCES THAT IT
DANGEROUSLY POLITICIZED AND
CORRUPTED OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
BEFORE VOTERS MAKE THAT DECISION
WE THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
HEAR ONCE AGAIN FROM TONY
BOBULINSKI.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS HE HAS
EARNED QUITE A BIT MORE ABOUT
THE BUSINESS DEALINGS, THE
CRIMINAL BUSINESS DEALINGS, OF
THE BIDEN FAMILY.
FOR THE NEXT HOUR WE WILL BRING
YOU THE RECENT CONVERSATION WITH
TOBY BOB BELINSKY